what's your take on the the sort of  boiling down of Christianity to the to  the sort of Trope that God is love what  does that mean and what is that supposed  to mean or is there something beyond  that I think that that statement is only  problematic in our society because we  have such a absurd view of what love is  uh a shallow view I should say we think  of love as just an emotional attachment  and so very often when we say we love  someone it's really about us we do what  we love about them what we love about  them is how they make us feel when we're  with them but that's not actually What  Love Is Love is uh is it was Aquinas  that the love is is willing the good of  the other that's what it means to love  someone's a very kind of simple way of  looking at if you really want what is  best for them in every sense spiritually  as well and you're going to work as much  as you can to to bring that up help them  bring that about in their own life and  then you love them